and it's been two years this weekend
since Hurricane Harvey made landfall in
Texas along with Hurricane Katrina
Harvey stands as the costliest storm on
record with damage estimated at a
hundred and twenty five billion dollars
the hard work of disaster recovery in
this country does not end when the
headlines go away a storm last hours or
days but it takes years for many to get
back on their feet
most disaster response focuses on the
immediate aftermath and that is
important but who stays behind long term
who does the work even today to handle
the mess left behind that story is the
latest in our continuing series who we
are
Houston had never seen anything like it
60 inches of rain in five days
Harvey damaged or destroyed 300,000
buildings and homes two years later the
recovery is far from over
what are the last two years and like
hail there are people like Allie and
Leonard Goss who lived in Houston their
entire lives this house has been here
since the 30s but it's never flooded
until now it literally knocked me off my
feet the water knocked you off your feet
oh yes it's Russian that it was that
Swift the gauss's escaped but were
unable to rebuild their ruined home
alone let's go out and do the thing all
right they were saved by a group called
all hands and hearts the Houston
operation is run by l.b cook our big
thing with with Harvey was arrive early
stay late do you think people still get
that do you think people still
understand how many people are without
homes how many people still have badly
damaged homes no cooks mostly volunteer
team live together for weeks or months
meeting in a community room sleeping in
small bunks during the day they fix
homes putting up new drywall replacing
appliances installing fixtures they
learn fast on the job from a 26 year old
fueled by a past disaster
hooks home in Mississippi was one of
hundreds of thousands destroyed by
Hurricane Katrina in 2005 her family
lived in a trailer for months her nine
year old sister went to the hospital for
pneumonia caused by black mold as a team
leader for all hands and hearts cook
runs a Houston operation constantly
cycling in and out new volunteers she
was also on the ground in Puerto Rico
after Hurricane Maria cook access
manager worker and friend
so I going on why do you do it because
somebody's got to do it for one and I
know what it was like before I had the
purpose when you know that there's
something out there and you're looking
for it and then you find it it's the
spot yeah it makes you feel good yeah
my mom was here last week she followed
me to Puerto Rico and I know she's proud
of me I'm proud of you I just met you
all hands and hearts believe they're
filling a space sorely lacking after a
natural disaster FEMA does give money to
homeowners but it's often miss spent and
rarely enough to cover the full cost of
rebuilding all Hansen hearts says they
put donated dollars directly into labor
and materials cutting out the middleman
here in Houston the group is also
rebuilding the home of 80 year old Ella
Hill she lives alone in the twilight of
her life who knows what would have
happened if all hands hadn't come to the
rescue
I like when when people ask how are you
doing you say blessed and blessed every
day well my as I expect a miracle and I
get it Ella Hills attitude is emboldened
by all hands people who were typically
more than half a century younger with no
incentive other than altruism folks have
been pretty helpful huh fantastic nobody
ever does anything for me they are yes
they and you saw the work yeah thank you
are gonna take pictures of it are we
have yeah oh it's weird
I know as the work at Hills home
continues at the Gauss's place after
seven months it's finally finishing the
Gauss's held hands throughout our
conversation not only did that beautiful
refrigerator come they brought a range I
couldn't believe it I started crying I
felt like an idiot but have you seen
them they're beautiful that's just what
I'm gonna pick that I love it you're so
happy oh you just don't know and give
him in the back in the house he needs to
be back in the house he's been poor
thing our cameras were rolling when the
keys were handed over the gauss's were
finally home again that night the
project was celebrated by the entire All
Hands team the coordinator on the
project one of LB cooks team leaders has
been working with the gauss's every day
from start to finish we completed the
house what do you think you're able to
do right now that other groups aren't I
mean we're still here and every day
we're working on different ways to to
close the gap to reach more people to
stay longer how can we use our resources
to do good work and empower people to be
able to move forward with their lives
selfless and unconditional dedication
you almost made her cry you almost made
me cry it's just a beautiful thing to
see when somebody gets their home back
how much that means some stranger
helping them yeah and the people working
on it right are 50 or 60 years younger
than them never knew them before
dedicate a year of their lives to making
someone happy and you'd be surprised how
many of these organizations I call them
pop ups are doing exactly what this one
is doing there's one called SBP they
started during after Hurricane Katrina
it is amazing someone is moved inspired
to help because they see a need then the
next disaster will happen there yes
certainly well and we hope that they
will be there for the
as well